vienne 1913 un spectacle présenté par la
compagnie influent en scène mardi 25 mai
au théâtre
coluche à plaisir une pièce qui raconte
les quatre années d'adolphe hitler à
bienne prémices d'un drame antisémite
qui a toute la culture dans la ville
viennoise il y as en émergence en
prémice donc le pire qui va naître
c'est à dire le l'antisémitisme le plus
békaa du plaisir
la pièce se joue dans un décor de
kiosque à musique sur scène neuf
comédiens interprètent un total de 23
personnages différents parmi lesquels
adolf hitler
la pièce s'ouvre sur le jour de ses 20
ans le 20 avril 1909 il vient de se
faire refuser à l'académie de vienne là
la difficulté c'est qu'effectivement il
faut laisser entrevoir le führer qui va
arriver mais il est pas encore là il est
encore jeune il est encore idéaliste
d'une certaine manière j'ai travaillé un
personnage qui est assez froid statique
cif mais néanmoins très précieux
dans la manière dont qu'il a de
s'exprimer je ne suis pas content ou pas
d'accord avec moi mon vote
alors comme ça tu dessines les bâtiments
pas seulement j'étudie wagner aussi ça
fait du bien aussi d'applaudir et
d'avoir eu ce beau spectacle en fait et
ça fait du bien de retrouver du théâtre
vivant avec des vrais acteurs devant
nous c'est vrai que ça traitaient d'un
sujet extrêmement grave
et malgré tout il ya une certaine
légèreté
prochain rendez-vous proposé par le
théâtre coluche pixels le spectacle de
danse hip hop aura lieu le 11 juin à
20h30
c'est une des plus belles chorégraphies
de mourad merzouki que j'ai pu voir
moi je connais tous ses spectacles à
chaque fois je dirais pour chacun de ses
spectacles sim plus beau mais celui là
il me tient à coeur parce que si c'est
celui par lequel j'ai découvert ce
chorégraphe et c'était tellement
fascinant tellement merveilleux que j'ai
hâte de le présenter au public de
plaisir une cinquantaine de
professionnels du spectacle étaient
présents à l'avant première
la représentation à destination du
public est programmée au 15 octobre